hey everybody rich roll here and the
lovely Julie Pyatt how's it goin we are
so proud to announce the launch of our
online plant-based nutrition program for
beginners that we produced in
partnership with mind body green calm
your destination for wellness I am an
ultra endurance triathlete
I always say that eating a plant-based
diet is the secret weapon of enhanced
athletic performance
I've done a race called Ultraman a
couple times which is a double Ironman
distance triathlon and I did an event
called epic five in which a friend of
mine and I completed five iron man's on
five different Hawaiian Islands in under
a week so what can we expect in this
course well we get thousands of emails
and letters asking for support and help
and advice on how to shift into a more
plant-based lifestyle and we're happy to
say that in this program we have support
information recipes nutrition facts all
kinds of information to support you in
making the shift into a more plant-based
lifestyle
I really wish something like this
existed when I started my journey there
is absolutely nothing else like this on
the market we have covered all the bases
we have hours and hours of online
content we have an online interactive
community for support and in fact you
can ask us questions and we can interact
with you there we also have downloadable
tools and resources so I encourage all
of you guys to go to mind/body Green
Comm purchase the program and get ready
to embark on this journey to enhance
vitality and
and wellness you are one click away from
changing your life
you